here with more now is the texas attorney
general
ken paxton first of all look i've got
i've got it all right here
highlighted all of it uh reddit cover to
cover
well done um i really first of all
why you decided to engage in this uh
tell us the law and the constitutional
principles that are at stake here
first of all you did a fantastic job
describing our lawsuit
it's really important to my state that
my voters be represented
and if other states don't follow the
constitution
and if their state legislature isn't
responsible for
overseeing their elections and we have
other people who are not under the
constitution
under the constitution supposed to be
doing this it affects my state
and so our job is to make sure that the
constitution's follow and that
every vote counts and in this case i'm
not sure that every vote was counted not
in the right way
let's go to the heart of this now number
one
let's start at the beginning article
three of the constitution
lists a very small number of categories
of cases that the supreme court has
original
jurisdiction in other words this does
not have to start at a
lower court explain that in the context
of now uh their response to your suit
earlier tonight so it's really important
point that you're bringing up
in a state on state suit our only place
to go is the u.s supreme court we can't
be heard anywhere else
other lawsuits start at a district court
level and they have a right to be heard
at least once whether they have a good
case or a bad case so
our request is we want to be heard the
only place we can go is the u.s supreme
court
and so we're pleading with the u.s
supreme court please hear
our case give us a chance at least to
argue what we think is right
we want to argue the constitution okay
now the supreme court has opined in the
past
it may decline to accept the case but
you know as we
watched all of this unfold today
um look uh we we had a different
possible outcome today
and that is you know we were waiting
today to see if the court would
would or would not hear the case and
now we have a briefing schedule correct
no that's a that's a good sign i really
appreciate that the court has asked
the other states to respond so we have a
chance hopefully
after they respond to to go to the court
and make our arguments on both sides and
at least
let the supreme court make a decision on
what is the law in this case
a question that they've never answered
as it relates to the the facts that
we're presenting
this is the point now this is where you
go into
very specific detail about
article two of the constitution and how
they violated what we call the elector's
clause uh when executive or judicial
officials in states
changed the rules of elections or
governing elections
that is constitutionally as clear and
unambiguous as anything in the
constitution
that there is one body that has that
constitutional authority and that would
be the state legislatures
sean you make a really important point
here it is the responsibility of state
legislatures per the constitution
to set the the rules for election of
electors and in this case
those were overridden in the four states
were talking about were overridden by
other
officials whether they were judges or
other governmental officials and that's
not the way our constitution
works and that's the challenge we have
in front of the court can this be
overridden by
people who are not responsible under the
constitution for doing this
mr attorney general can you explain how
the elector's clause in georgia michigan
pa and wisconsin
were violated yeah so in almost all
those cases
that we have we have states that that
allowed mail-in ballots in cases they
were not supposed to
they allowed for non-signature
verification which is really important
so when you
when you request a mail-in ballot you
have to sign for that
for that application and then they'll
verify when you send your ballot in
on a sleeve of the ballot usually
they'll verify that signature
to ensure that those two signatures
match well if you just waive those
requirements you have no way to go back
and verify
that the person that requested the
application is the person voting that's
a pretty important thing
when in pennsylvania you go from 233 000
mail-in ballots four years ago to 2.5
million and the difference
in the election was only 81 000. that's
a very important
issue to to ignore what's fascinating
about this suit is at no point do you
even have to
go to the area approving fraud which i
think was proven in a lot of these
states that's separate and apart
and and those cases run independently in
a lot of the states we're talking about
but let's talk about the second
constitutional violation that you point
out in your suit
and and actually you rely on the
landmark
landmark case of bush v gore where the
supreme
court held the violated the equal
protection clause in the 14th amendment
and that when one one florida county
treated ballots one way that was
you know chad swinging hanging
perforated pimpled and dimpled
and they did it differently from county
to county
and voters had the constitutional right
to have
all ballots in the state of florida
treated equally county to county
explain how that comes into play in this
suit
well i think that explains the wisdom of
the constitution requiring that a
statewide body
of legislators make the rules instead of
allowing county by county
distinctions that are different where
people are treated differently in
different states and i think that was
part of the genius of what the founders
put in place is
making sure that everybody in the state
was at least treated the same
in this case in all four states we have
county by county
distinctions that treated voters
differently and we therefore
have unreliable results and that's a
problem
you also talk about remedy in the
lawsuit
and you're asking the supreme court to
remand the appointment of electors in
these four
states back to the state legislators
and there's even the mcpherson blacker
case of 1892 that i would argue probably
was precedent setting in this regard as
well
uh am i right about that no you're
absolutely right and this
is was was traditional in our country it
was it was not uncommon for
legislative bodies to elect their
elector so
we're saying hey look the the the
results here we can't go back and
let the put the genie back in the bottle
because we don't know how to match up
signatures anymore because they they
were separated from the ballot
since we can't go back and do that we
want to go back to the legislature and
let them make a decision since they were
elected by the people of the states
all right mr attorney general
fascinating it's going to be an
interesting week to watch uh and hope
they have the courage thank you sir